et même si les systèmes de défense du
traitant ont réussi à intercepter 51 des
70 missiles envoyés par la Russie hier
et bien on compte malgré tout au moins 6
morts et 36 blessés dans la capitale
tiède tandis qu'hier matin et maternité
avait été touché par les bombardements à
villeignan près de vaporizia dans une
maternité un nouveau-né y a perdu la vie
donc le Parlement européen hier a
qualifié la Russie d'états promoteurs du
terrorisme mais le président ukrainien
volo demeures qui parle de crime contre
l'humanité avec ses attaques qui mettent
des millions de personnes dans une
grande précarité énergétique parce qu'il
y a d'un côté c'est pertes civil très
direct très violente et très soudaine et
d'un autre en disant les infrastructures
énergétiques et bien le risque de crise
humanitaire est très très prégnant alors
que l'hiver ça fait déjà bien sentir ici
mais on est qu'en novembre et au cours
de l'hiver les températures elles
peuvent s'attendre les -20 degrés et en
Ukraine l'OMS a rappelé qu'il pouvait
s'agir d'une question de survie pour des
millions d'ukrainien et